[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a comedy film called 60
million dollar man spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
[Music]
singh is a spoiled rich youngster living
in hawaii he has a dozen servants who
bring him breakfast in bed help him take
showers and dress him up every day his
life is unlike anyone else's as he has a
very peculiar way of doing normal things
for instance he only gargles with fresh
cow milk only takes a bath in his
swimming pool with a bunch of women and
only travels by helicopter tat is
singh's personal assistant who manages
everything in sing's life because sing
has always gotten everything he wanted
he has developed a hobby of troubling
everyone around him one morning tat and
singh bored a helicopter to fly to sings
college all the students in the college
know him as the spoiled brat who plays
silly pranks still because of his
father's influence no one dares to go
against him singh's usual target is the
school loner named sue fu he breaks the
toilet's wall when sufu is inside of it
to humiliate him in front of everyone
the poor guy bawls his eyes out and runs
away naked and embarrassed as sing and
tat laugh at yet another successful
prank they are approached by a new girl
named chung chung initially she startles
sing because of her ugliness he is
furious that she got admitted to their
college because he had especially told
the principal to only take in beautiful
girls with nicer bodies chung chung
reveals that she is the daughter of the
science teacher professor chang unlike
the others she isn't scared of sing and
his influence she calls him out for the
stupid prank much to sing's annoyance
later during professor chang's class
singh arrives late as usual the other
students give him space and move further
away except for chung chung who stays
put the professor overlooks sings
ignorant behavior and continues teaching
he talks about a new technology that
will allow people to be turned into
cyborgs when he dissects a dead body to
show them the visual representation of
the theory the students can hardly keep
themselves from passing out during the
lunch break sing and tat come to the
cafeteria and everyone else walks away
afraid of him again chung chung is the
only one who sits right beside him and
continues eating singh threatens to get
her fired but professor chang who is
nearby says that it won't be possible
the professor also calls him the most
disgusting student he has ever had if it
weren't for his father being the
director of the college singh would have
been beaten to death by the people he
troubles on the daily to test if his
classmates would really do something
like that he blurts out that his father
is not the director of the school when
the other students hear this they do not
waste their time before piling on top of
sing and beating him up sing is left
furious after the incident he and tat
break into the professor's house at
night to teach him a lesson they set up
bear traps in the basement lab hoping
that the professor will fall right into
it but then as they are about to leave
tat notices a cut off hand walking on
its own initially singh thinks tad is
joking and asks him to focus seconds
later a pair of eyes stares at them
startling the two they struggle to get a
hold of the hand but it runs away into a
corner on trying to pull it out sing
comes across a half human body the duo
thinks they're being haunted by a ghost
and they run away on his way out tat
falls into the bear trap and hertz is
behind a while later they call the
police suspecting that the professor is
conducting experiments by dissecting
people's body parts the police search
everywhere but cannot find the said pair
of eyes or the hand they think the idea
is absurd and accuse singh of wasting
their time in the end they evacuate tad
and sing out of the house after everyone
leaves the hand and eyes reappear behind
the professor revealing that they are in
fact one of his cyborg experiments the
following day singh is paranoid that the
professor will send the body parts to
trouble him again hence he dresses up in
football gear ready to defend himself in
case anyone tries to harm him singh's
father arrives from china to give him a
surprise but is beaten up by his son
after being mistaken for an intruder
following that someone knocks on their
front door on checking singh finds a
seductive woman named bonnie asking him
to help her bathe it turns out that she
is a neighbor who has been watching him
for a long time singh doesn't miss the
chance to take her to his personal
swimming pool where the two clean each
other that night they go to a club and
drink a lot as they are dancing bonnie
sees her husband enter the club she
reveals that her husband is a local
crime lord named fumito the couple tries
their best to hide but the organizer of
a show announces them the winner of a
dancing competition when the spotlight
falls on the couple they catch the
entire club's attention fumito fumes in
anger upon seeing his wife with someone
else he and his henchmen bring the two
to his house to teach them a lesson on
reaching home singh passes out drunk
bonnie tries helping him but is knocked
out when singh suddenly wakes up and
hits her he somehow gets to his car and
drives away while the gangsters follow
him on reaching home singh is out of
breath and terrified he tries to tell
his mother what happened but she cuts
him off claiming that she has something
more important to say she confesses that
she slept with tad 20 years ago this
means that the millionaire businessman
pay is not actually singh's father but
his assistant is pay overhears their
conversation and calls his wife a [ __ ]
although it is revealed that an ugly guy
like singh is not his biological son he
is heartbroken by his wife's betrayal
tat also joins the conversation and asks
singh to stay as his son now that
everyone knows the truth however singh
wants 2 million dollars and is willing
to continue being pai's son for money
tat is distressed because he always
loved seeing his family sing on the
other hand kicks him out of the house to
receive money from pay he did what he
had to in the heat of the moment but the
following day singh is guilt-ridden he
always had tat by his side growing up
and after knowing that he is his father
singh cannot help but to feel sorry
later that day he goes to the church for
self-reflection and finds chung chung he
tells her what he did yesterday and how
bad he feels chung chung also begins to
realize that he's not as bad as she
thought he was that evening the gangster
fumito sends his right-hand man mark to
kill singh they get into a chase around
the house when suddenly the lights go
off when they turn back on we see that
tat has come to save his son he puts his
life in danger for sing but the two are
caught in the end then their hands are
cuffed together in the bathroom stall
where mark has planted a bomb after the
gangsters leave the father and son only
have a few seconds before the explosive
goes off singh takes responsibility for
the first time and cuts his arm off so
that tat can escape in the following
explosion tat survives but singh passes
away what the hell is going on in this
movie the next day singh's case is
brought to professor chang he reveals
that although singh technically died in
the explosion his lips remained unharmed
using the technology he has recently
been developing he can reform sing's
body with artificial parts keeping only
his lips intact tat speaks to his son's
lips and assures him that he will be
fine however the cost of surgery is 60
million dollars pay calls sing and asks
him to get rid of tat if he wants the
money for surgery but zing has come to
his senses even though he is only a pair
of lips he renounces his rich father and
decides to stay dead not wanting to
abandon tat again pat begs the professor
to perform the surgery using the six
thousand dollars that he has chang feels
bad for the desperate father and agrees
to perform the procedure but the results
won't be as good as he will have to
makeshift the body parts with whatever
things he has following that the
professor spends days and nights
aggressively pinching and pushing the
body for the first few tries many things
go wrong sometimes sing wakes up with a
square head sometimes with a tiny hand
and other times with hands attached to
his lower body instead of legs then a
few weeks later everything works out and
sing is turned back to his older self
but with makeshift body parts since he
is now a cyborg his body runs on a
battery that can die at any time zing
has to be careful with his life but he
is overjoyed to finally be back alive
while the professor could find an
alternative for all of his body parts
finding a male genital was impossible
hence currently sing has a faucet that
helps him pee man that guy's hung like a
sink in the following scene a funeral is
held for sing so the gangsters won't
look for him again no one comes to the
funeral except for chung chung who is
genuinely sad about his death singh sees
her from afar and is happy that at least
someone cares about him cut to two years
later singh currently lives with his
father and has been looking for a job he
eats batteries for every meal and has
changed his genitals to his shower head
instead of a faucet one day his college
classmate sue fu offers him a job as a
teacher in a school singh is overjoyed
that he finally gets to earn money for
himself but little does he know he's
about to face the worst students in the
country on his first day at work he's
instantly attacked with buckets full of
water and paintballs his fellow teacher
saves him from the attack and brings him
to a safer place he reveals that 50 of
the teachers who have come to teach
these students have resigned in only one
day the rest have either turned into
handicaps died or gone crazy with a
renewed motivation to be the most strict
teacher possible singh enters the
classroom he shows the students a knife
to assert his dominance but the
youngsters trap him in a net and throw
their bags at him the principal of the
school doesn't care because the students
are the children of powerful and wealthy
businessmen by the end of the day singh
is heavily beaten up and crucified to
the school's gate with his shower head
hanging out all of a sudden chung chung
appears and recognizes him she has
turned into a beautiful and confident
girl in contrast to how she was before
she tries to help but sing smugly claims
that he can do it himself moments later
she gets into a sports car with her rich
boyfriend and drives away much to
singh's disappointment that night at
home singh has lost all hope the
professor comes to meet him and
discloses that he has invented a chip
that will turn sing into a superhero
basically with the help of the said ship
he will be able to transform into
anything singh is skeptical but he
trusts the professor with his body after
the chip is implanted singh thinks of
turning into a rice cooker and to his
surprise he does then he turns into a
toothpaste tube and spends the rest of
the night like that now that he has
superhuman powers sing goes to impress
chengcheng with them he finds her at a
restaurant having dinner with her
boyfriend and his parents when she
excuses herself and goes to the bathroom
singh follows her he claims to be a
changed person and begs her to be his
girlfriend to showcase his skills he
even transforms into a strange toilet
not what i would have gone for but cool
when chung chung is still not impressed
he takes over a magic show happening in
the restaurant and shows his powers to
the audience by the end of the night he
is flying in the sky with chengchang
using an umbrella as a parachute
unimpressed chung chung agrees to date
him the next day singh goes to the
school confidently he transforms his
hand into a water hose and teaches the
students a lesson for messing with him
eventually they start to obey him and
turn into good students everything goes
well in sing's life until one day the
gangster mark finds out he is still
alive and attacks him they get into a
fight but sing defeats him easily with
his new powers mark's boss fumito is not
someone who gives up easily he turns
mark into a cyborg as well but he
budgets the surgery with 60 million
dollars and makes him even better than
singh a few days later singh and chung
chung are getting married sioux fu comes
to the wedding but singh recognizes him
as mark in disguise the party is
interrupted as the two get into a fight
mark terrorizes everyone and starts
firing randomly amidst the chaos he
fires a special weapon at singh that
kills him instantly everyone is in shock
until singh revives from his burnt dead
body resembling an old woman in a robe
the professor discloses that the chip
turns singh's revenge mode on when he is
defeated which means that he is now more
powerful than ever singh transforms into
a giant steam iron and flattens his
opponent following that he turns into a
microwave and traps mark inside the
professor starts the microwave from
outside which melts mark and finally
kills him in the last scene we see the
professor hitting on sing because of his
appearance as an old woman chung chung
playfully asks her father to back off
because she is marrying sing subscribe
for more videos like this whatever this
was turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out